what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have some fantastic four news
today that some fans are finding quite
controversial but it looks like we might
have our next Sue storm and this time we
kind of have more evidence than we've
ever had before with any of these rumors
or fan castings and let's be honest
there have been a lot and recently some
of the actors who have been kind of
thrown out there in the fire for the fan
casting rumors have spoken up and all
basically denied that no I'm not going
to be playing anyone in the Fantastic
Four but of course as we know from the
past you can deny you are playing a role
and then end up playing the role the
perfect example is Paul Rudd as Ant-Man
when asked about the role in the past
before Ant-Man 1 came out he denied it
said he wasn't playing Ant-Man but of
course he was and that is because they
obviously can't just come out and say
why yes that rumor is true I am playing
this character especially when it comes
to somebody as big as a Fantastic Four
member one of the biggest casting rumors
was that pin badge actually was going to
be playing Mr Fantastic and a lot of
people actually really liked this but
recently he has denied that and some
insiders like my time to shine hello
have said that he wasn't actually ever
considered for the role that was just a
rumor but today we have a little bit
more concrete evidence of to who could
be playing Sue storm AKA The Invisible
Woman in the MCU because Mila Kunis was
actually spotted meeting with Matt
shackman the director of the Fantastic
Four Now Matt shackman really has only
one thing going on for the next couple
of years and he's already actually said
this himself and that is the Fantastic
Four so if he is meeting with an actress
about something an upcoming project of
his that project is most likely the
Fantastic Four the only other projects
that he's worked on is the consultant
which is already completed and the
Untitled Apple Godzilla project which
has been in production so casting is
complete for that project as well so if
he is meeting with Mila Kunis about a
role it's for the Fantastic Four because
that is all he is committed to for the
next few years and again he stated this
in a recent interview that that's all
he's focused on that's all he's working
on he's not taking on anything else just
focusing on the Fantastic Four so Mila
Kunis was spotted meeting with him
leading us to believe that she could be
our next Sue storm especially because it
does seem like they are very very close
to finalizing who they want to play the
members of the Fantastic Four director
Matt shackman recently revealed that
they are going to begin filming early
2024 and a lot of people are stating
okay well where's the cast if you're
getting that close shouldn't you have
already gotten your cast and it looks
like we are getting pretty close plus
Insider my time to shine hello also
commented on the report from fandom wire
that Mila kudis was spotted with Matt
shackman stating she'll be great
seemingly kind of backing up this
narrative that Mila Kunis is indeed
going to be the next invisible woman now
I'm assuming they'll make her blonde
give her the classic Sue storm look and
of course with makeup and her costume
and CGI and everything that goes into
the production of a movie they could
really make her look the part and I
personally really like Mila Kunis she's
only done a few kind of action movies
Jupiter Ascending being one of them and
I think if done correctly she could make
a good invisible woman but hey let me
know what you all think about this in
the comments down below do you like this
as far as a sue Storm Casting or would
you rather have somebody else let us
know all of your thoughts in the
comments about Mila Kunis as Sue storm
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe stay up to date on all the
latest Fantastic Four and MCU news for
live updates you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
thank you